[Musique]
alors je le rappelle l'artiste barré
vous êtes conseiller un municipal en
charge du bien-être animal pour la ville
de Poissy et ce soir vous allez nous
parler de la tonte des moutons
exactement ce que je vais vous parler de
bien-être animal avec la tonte des
moutons les moutons ne mutent pas et ils
ont besoin de l'intervention de l'homme
pour l'aider à se refaire une peau neuve
et donc c'est à cette période de l'année
qu'on commence à tondre les moutons oui
alors en fait la tombe des moutons a
lieu une seule fois dans l'année et donc
c'est au mois d'avril au mois de mai au
mois d'avril on te découvre pas d'un fil
mais au mois de mai c'est un petit
rappel mais
n'oubliez pas de faire la tente de vos
moutons puisque c'est très indispensable
pour la santé de nos moutons la laine
donc le mouton en fait il produit 3 à 5
kg de laine par an cet oiseau elle va
être épaisse elle sera remplie de
pailles comme vous pouvez le constater
de crottin le mouton il va produire du
soin de la graisse qui est sécrétée par
la peau et donc c'est vraiment
indispensable pour lui de
qu'on lui effectue sa tonte oui ça va
permettre plusieurs choses notamment au
niveau des maladies puis aussi du
troupeau tout à fait donc ça va
permettre d'assainir le troupeau de
limiter les maladies et puis le mouton
lui va se sentir plus léger ça va
stimuler également son appétit les
agneaux vont pouvoir téter les mamelles
de leur maman également pour la mise à
bas de ça va être plus simple ça va le
mouton bah il va pouvoir mettre à bas
tranquillement et ça ira moins de
risques de s'étouffer et puis la tente
également elle n'est pas douloureuse
elle va permettre d'inspecter votre
mouton voire est-ce qu'il est maigre
est-ce qu'il avait besoin de soins et
alors à quoi va servir toute cette laine
après alors cette laine on a parlé de
Fashion éco-responsable on est bien dans
le thème donc va servir en fait depuis
deux ans et demi moi je m'en sers grâce
aux agents déjà de la ville de Poissy je
la récupère pour en faire derrière déjà
les parties qui sont crottées en servir
au jardin au niveau des potagers donc
pour faire du paillage et il est parti
qui sont propres elles seront lavées et
ben ma maman qui couturière elle elle
s'en sert donc les elles on les lave au
niveau de la terrasse et il en ressort
comme ça des coussins et là voilà on
peut faire des doudous ça c'est mon
doudou à moi on peut en faire des
doudous pour les bébés d'ailleurs on
félicite notre Mickaël pour la minute de
son bébé on lui fera peut-être un petit
doudou pourquoi pas oui c'est une bonne
idée et on s'en sert aussi on peut voir
peut-être bien sûr
j'en ai un sac aussi
[Rires]
du fromage
mais c'est pas un odeur désagréable mais
ça semble naturel ça sent naturel si on
doit décrire l'odeur c'est l'odeur de la
ferme franchement si on rentre dans une
étable c'est l'autre
en tout cas nickel
je peux vous rassurer Michael c'est très
doux c'est très doux
c'est bon aussi pour les articulations
pour il y a de la présence de l'anoline
à l'intérieur donc pour nos chroniqueurs
sportifs qui font trop de sport j'en
laisserai aussi j'ai tout un sac rempli
j'ai pas tout sorti sur le plateau
effectivement je pense à Céline et
général
j'en profite pour remercier donc nos
agents de la ville de Poissy puisqu'il
hier ils nous ont ouvert les portes on a
pu faire la tonte ils nous ont alors ils
ont mis les moutons à l'aise la tente
était vraiment magnifique puis nous ont
mis à l'aise aussi moi j'étais plus
stressée que que les moutons
je remercie donc Alexis Guillot Monsieur
Serge les ouf Carl cousin madame Irène
Perrault bien sûr madame le Maire sandre
et dos Santos nous avoir autorisé à
venir tourner merci à Nicolas d'être
venu pour les images
faut bien insister là dessus les moutons
ne souffrent pas au moment de la tonte
alors c'est vrai qu'il se débattent un
peu parce que la position n'est pas
évidente pour eux mais c'est vraiment
pour leur santé et puis il y a vraiment
une technique et Mathilde vous souvenez
sûrement qu'on avait fait qu'on avait
participé à une formation justement au
berger à la Bergerie Nationale
il y a vraiment une formation et on voit
que hier les agents ont été formés à ça
et qui se prennent vraiment l'attention
pour bien positionner le mouton et faire
la tour et en plus avec la main gauche
on a de la technique
et on avait également la présence de
l'élu de Chanteloup qui était là hier
soir hier madame Sophie Chergui que je
remercie elle était venue pouvoir
l'agneau Louise Louise qui s'était perdu
dans les roues dans les rues de
Chanteloup et cet agneau a été recueilli
par la mammifère de Poissy et il me
semble que vous vouliez dire un petit
mot sur sur les cochons d'inde par
rapport à la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière Mathilde nous avons parlé des
cochons on a eu un fort succès
d'ailleurs il y a l'association Les
Petites patachons du 59 qui nous
regardent Maroilles alors déjà je leur
passe mes salutations je les félicite
pour le très beau travail qui font pour
l'adoption des cochons d'Inde et je vous
laisse souligner à nouveau qu'il faut
bien adopter vos animaux à la SPA je ne
le souligne pas assez parce que pour moi
c'est une évidence de passer à la SPA ou
beaucoup d'animaux vous attendent ils
recherchent des familles beaucoup
d'amour et du bonheur et puisque vous
appréciez l'émission la chronique
bien-être animal ce qu'on commence à
avoir pas mal de messages n'hésitez pas
continuer à nous envoyer des mails avec
vos suggestions et les sujets que vous
souhaitez voir et bien merci beaucoup
Baptiste barré pour tous vos précieux
conseils on vous retrouve prochainement
pour pour une nouvelle chronique pour
une nouvelle chronique très
prochainement donc on verra de quoi vous
allez nous parler plus tard c'est ça
peut-être de votre chat a-t-il
de mon chat